[Música]
en directo américa es hora de hablar de
economía por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido vamos a iniciar en reino
unido donde la nueva primera ministra
liz torres admitió que algunas de sus
medidas económicas pueden ser
impopulares bueno parece que todos está
dispuesta a enfrentar la mayor crisis
económica del reino unido en décadas el
viernes el ministro de economía casa we
catering presentará un programa para
abordar la elevada inflación en el que
se prevé que retire límites a las
bonificaciones de los banqueros cancelen
las subidas previstas del impuesto de
sociedades y elimine gravámenes para
sufragar la transición ecológica pero
dijo que quería conseguir una economía
con salarios más altos ya que el
trabajador medio ahí quedan actualmente
unas nueve mil libras menos al año como
resultado de más de una década de
estancamiento del salario el equipo de
trolls también ha mencionado cambios en
las tasas empresariales y recortes del
impuesto al valor agregado para ayudar a
la crisis energética así que un así como
una revisión a más largo plazo de estos
impuestos tras el periodo de luto
nacional por la muerte de la reina según
datos y sus ministros comenzarán en los
próximos días a detallar estos planes de
gobierno bueno y continuar las sanciones
a rusia por su invasión a ucrania y es
que las medidas que tomaron los
prestamistas turcos ins bank y dennis
bank para suspender el uso de sistemas
de pago ruso mir abrió la puerta a
nuevos bloqueos de otros bancos por
temor a caer en sanciones la suspensión
de dos de los cinco bancos turcos que
utilizaban este sistema muestra los
esfuerzos por evitar el cruce financiero
entre occidente y rusia mientras el
gobierno turco adopta una postura
diplomática equilibrada turquía que es
miembro de la otan se opone a las
sanciones occidentales contra rusia y
mantiene estrechos vínculos tanto con
moscú como con sus vecinos aunque
también condenó la invasión rusa en
ucrania y envió drones armados a ese
país como parte de su equilibrio
diplomático mir que es este sistema de
pagos ruso es popular sobre todo entre
los miles de turistas rusos que llegan a
turquía o que llegaron a turquía durante
este año el mes pasado el tesoro de eeuu
envió una misiva a las grandes empresas
turcas en las que les advertía
se arriesgaban las sanciones se
mantenían vínculos comerciales con los
rusos sancionados bueno y en plena
crisis energética alemania está a punto
de nacionalizar el importador de gas un
híper así es alemán ya estaría dispuesta
a comprar la participación del 78 por
ciento de fortune en un híper y a
inyectar otros 8 mil millones de dólares
en el grupo energético para lograr una
participación superior al 90 por ciento
un hiper que es el mayor importador de
gas ruso de alemania agoto sus reservas
en efectivo al comprar gas en el mercado
al contado después de que rusia cortara
los flujos lo que desencadenó un paquete
de rescate con berlín que se acordó en
julio pasado el gobierno alemán puso a
gazprom germanía y a una filial de la
petrolera rusa rosneft bajo tutela o
bajo una nacionalización de facto vamos
ahora a puerto rico porque apenas las
autoridades están comenzando a hacer un
recuento de los daños causados por el
huracán fiona bueno hasta ahora el 80
por ciento de los casi 15 millones de
clientes
electricidad en la isla seguían sin el
servicio y el 55% de los hogares no
tenían agua potable según el sistema de
portales de emergencia de puerto rico el
huracán tocó tierra en puerto rico el
domingo causando daños en
infraestructura y edificios el
gobernador de puerto rico pedro
pierluisi anunció este martes que va a
someter al presidente eeuu joe biden a
una petición de declaración de desastre
mayor actualmente unas 1200 personas
están en 70 refugios en su mayoría
establecidos en algunos colegios el
sistema eléctrico del territorio
estadounidense nunca se ha recuperado de
la devastación causada hace cinco años
precisamente por otro huracán al huracán
maría jorge y los usuarios de spotify en
eeuu ya pueden comprar audiolibros el
negocio de los libros ahí representa o
está valorado en unos 140 mil millones
de dólares la plataforma anunció que
desde hoy podrán comprar y escuchar más
de 300 mil títulos de audio y libros
diferentes la plataforma de spotify
quiere ser el monopolio de audio la
empresa introdujo los podcast en el año
2015 y ahora alberga a más de 44 mil de
ellos según su informe de resultado del
segundo trimestre de este año el
movimiento también pone sport y fine en
una competencia más directa con audible
propiedad de amazon que fue el líder del
mercado en el 2018 con el 41% de la
cuota de mercado de audiolibro otros
competidores son apple google y rakuten
pues porque estas muchas gracias por
esta ampliación económica aquí en
directo américa vamos ahora con el
debate
[Música]